on pourrait croire que c'est la bande
annonce d'un nouveau film de
science-fiction mais non ces projets
sont censés voir le jour d'ici 2030 en
Arabie Saoudite alors je dis qu'ils sont
censés voir le jour parce que vous allez
voir c'est pas forcément gagné vous
allez pourquoi de tel construction bien
la réalité c'est que derrière ces images
il y a un projet et une vision un projet
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand
[Musique]
pour répondre à cette question il faut
remonter quelques années en arrière en
2017 en France c'est l'année où Emmanuel
Macron est officiellement élu président
pour la première fois et bien à 6000 km
de là cette même année un autre homme
prend également la tête de son pays cet
homme c'est Mohamed Ben Salman surnommé
MBS il devient le 21 juin 2017 le prince
héritier d'Arabie Saoudite il prend de
fait le pouvoir dans le pays à 32 ans
donc il prend la tête de cette monarchie
absolue islamique un pays qui fait
quatre fois la taille de la France au
droit de l'homme régulièrement bafoué
parmi les pays les plus autoritaires du
monde mais un pays avec qui peu de monde
finalement peut s'embrouiller et la
raison de cette entente avec beaucoup de
pays du monde elle tient en un mot
le pétrole
vous l'aurez compris Mohamed Ben Salman
et donc l'homme derrière ses projets
gigantesques il est l'homme qui veut
faire de l’arabie Saoudite une
superpuissance mondiale mais en 2018 les
débuts sont extrêmement délicats ses
débuts tiennent notamment à un nom
jamais rassuji nous sommes en 2018
lorsque ce journaliste saoudien qui
critiquait le pouvoir et Mohamed Ben
Salman est assassiné par un commando
saoudien au consulat d'Arabie saoudite à
Istanbul en Turquie je vous en avais
parlé à l'époque sur cette même chaîne
Youtube MBS et rapidement soupçonné
d'avoir commandité l'opération jusqu'à
ce jour il dément formellement avoir
ordonné l'assassinat du journaliste et
c'est là qu'on comprend très bien à quel
point l'Arabie Saoudite et MBS détient
une influence importante sur le monde
car malgré cette histoire qui a fait le
tour du monde et un dîner de nombreuses
ONG de défense des droits de l'homme et
bien beaucoup de chefs d'État ne
semblent pas trop lui en tenir compte
MBS devient même assez rapidement
quelqu'un qu'il vaut mieux avoir comme
ami que comme ennemi et la raison est
toujours la même le pétrole en 2022 il
est ainsi accueilli à bras ouverts en
Europe et notamment par Emmanuel Macron
en France MBS arrive à Paris en pleine
guerre en Ukraine et clairement il est
en position de force en France il sait
que l'Europe veut réduire son
importation de pétrole russe depuis
l'invasion en Ukraine il n'a plus qu'à
avancer ses pions pour devenir un acteur
majeur sur le sujet au lendemain
d'ailleurs du dîner entre Emmanuel
Macron et MBS la presse saoudienne va
même se réjouir de cette situation en
titrant en une dans le quotidien Al Riad
l'Europe compense le pétrole russe par
le pétrole saoudien le pétrole sauve
donc l'Arabie Saoudite il lui permet de
développer ses relations malgré le
non-respect des droits de l'homme mais
Mohamed Ben Salman veut aller plus loin
il veut être une grande puissance une
puissance qui impressionne au-delà du
pétrole et on va voir dans quelques
instants la question de ces immenses
projets mais avant ça on va parler aussi
de cette puissance diplomatique capable
de nouer des relations au-delà de son
économie en effet et notamment depuis le
début de l'invasion à grande échelle de
l'Ukraine par la Russie l'Arabie
Saoudite fait partie de ces pays qui
veulent jouer un rôle dans la résolution
du conflit en mars par exemple le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
saoudiens était à Moscou pour rencontrer
son homologue russe Sergueï lavrof Riad
propose sa médiation dans la guerre
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine c'est ainsi
que titré le quotidien saoudien
donationnel au lendemain de cette
rencontre ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
là c'est que historiquement l'Arabie
Saoudite est alliée des États-Unis
encore une fois principalement pour son
pétrole mais donc ses dernières années
et notamment depuis l'arrivée de MBS la
diplomatie saoudienne essaie de se
diversifier elle essaie en gros
d'exister sans être rangé
systématiquement derrière les États-Unis
suite par exemple à l'assassinat
journaliste Jamal rachodji qui a donc
tendu les relations avec les États-Unis
on a vu l'Arabie Saoudite et bien
entendre les mains tendre des relations
avec d'autres États et ça on le voit par
exemple avec début de l'année 2023 le
rétablissement de relation diplomatiques
entre l’arabie Saoudite et l'Iran ça
intéressant à observer pour deux raisons
déjà parce que l'Iran et l'ennemi juré
des États-Unis et donc se rapprochement
est un élément important élément aussi
important parce que c'est rapprochement
entre l'Iran et l'Arabie saoudite a été
permis grâce au travail de médiation de
la Chine la Chine autre rival importante
des États-Unis d'ailleurs pour marquer
encore plus la prise de distance avec
les États-Unis et bien les dirigeants
saoudiens ont bien souligné dans la
presse que la Chine était je cite
désormais un acteur majeur de la
sécurité et de la stabilité du golf
clairement on peut pas faire plus clair
comme pied de nez aux États-Unis alors
que retenir de tout ça et bien elle
Arabie Saoudite veut s'affirmer comme
grande puissance via son pétrole certes
mais aussi via de nouvelles relations
diplomatiques et surtout donc via
d'immenses projets
[Musique]
impressionnant effectivement vision 2030
c'est donc le grand projet de MBS pour
l'Arabie Saoudite l'objectif de ce
projet est très simple diversifié
l'économie du pays une économie qui
repose à plus de 70% aujourd'hui sur
l'exportation de pétrole MBS c'est que
dans un monde préoccupé par le
changement climatique le pétrole assez
limite il doit donc trouver d'autres
sources de revenus alors il faut savoir
que depuis son plus jeune âge MBS aime
particulièrement tout ce qui touche à la
technologie et à l'innovation on le dit
même fasciné par la réussite de Mark
Zuckerberg par exemple et puis
contrairement aux précédents rois qui
ont dirigé l'Arabie Saoudite MBS
maîtrise l'anglais you can be do what
way want to do l'usage des réseaux
sociaux ça lui permet donc rapidement de
s'entourer notamment des meilleurs
ingénieurs des ingénieurs parfois
eux-mêmes formés aux États-Unis qu'il
réussit donc à faire venir à ses côtés
l'objectif donc faire de l'Arabie
Saoudite une grande puissance
technologique tout cela à un objectif
derrière attirer tout simplement les
touristes et diversifier donc plus
largement son économie alors ça peut
paraître assez simple dit comme ça mais
il faut bien comprendre que le tourisme
c'est vraiment quelque chose de nouveau
pour l'Arabie Saoudite en fait
historiquement le pays était fermé au
tourisme il n'était tout simplement pas
possible d'obtenir un visa de tourisme
classique et c'est seulement depuis 2019
que le pays a commencé à s'ouvrir au
touristes internationaux simplement pour
aller visiter comme ça le pays
[Musique]
de Fest tu visites get sur visa now
autrement dit soyez les premiers à venir
visiter obtenez votre visa maintenant le
visage est assez clair MBS veut même
attirer 100 millions de touristes par an
et pour ça il mise sur plusieurs volets
alors ça a commencé en 2019 par la mise
en avant de la culture et du patrimoine
de l'Arabie Saoudite cette année là
c'est le site historique Daloula qui est
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
qui a ouvert ses portes pour la première
fois au visiteurs d'ailleurs petite
anecdote au passage le Petit Futé qui
est une collection donc de guides
touristiques vient tout juste en mars
2023 de sortir ça le tout premier guide
en français pour visiter l'Arabie
Saoudite preuve donc visiblement que le
tourisme est en train de se développer
mais MBS c'est que ça ne suffira pas
pour attirer des visiteurs d'où son
intérêt pour faire de l'Arabie Saoudite
un pays à la pointe de la technologie
alors si jamais vous n'avez pas encore
vu après le bombardement de publicité
sur tous les réseaux sociaux ces
derniers jours voici NEOM un énorme
projet de construction dans la région de
Tabouk dans le nord-ouest de l'Arabie
Saoudite se situait juste ici alors je
suis consciente comme ça ça ne parle pas
forcément à tout le monde ce territoire
mais c'est un territoire qui est très
stratégique à l'intersection de trois
continents et à l'embouchure du canal de
Suez une voix notamment essentielle pour
le commerce mondial puisque plus de 50
navires passent chaque jour ici NEOM
c'est donc un projet qui réunit pas une
pas deux mais bien trois nouvelles
villes des villes toutes plus
incroyables les unes que les autres vous
allez le voir première ville j'ai nommé
de Line une ville construite comme une
ligne comme son nom l'indique de plus de
170 km de long 500 mètres de haut et 200
mètres de large il y a aussi Hexagon
hexagone vous le prononcez comme vous le
souhaitez c'est un projet de ville
flottante bâtie sur l'eau en forme
d'octogone et enfin il y a trop Genas
construite à 2000 mètres d'altitude dans
les montagnes avec une station de ski
artificiel en plein désert au total
c'est un projet de plus de 26000 km²,
donc presque aussi gros que la Belgique
estimée à plus de 500 milliards de
dollars avec des matériaux tous plus
innovants les uns que les autres toutes
les technologies dernier cri dont
l'intelligence artificielle à cela vient
s'ajouter un autre projet
urbain tout aussi futuriste qui a été
présenté au début de l'année 2023 j'ai
nommé le mucab en gratte-ciel doré de
400 mètres de côté installé directement
dans la capitale de l'Arabie Saoudite
Ryad et je vous passe les détails mais à
l'intérieur de ce cube on retrouve une
tour en spirale avec les magasins des
lieux culturels et des attractions
touristiques mais aussi d'ailleurs des
résidences et des hôtels bref tout ce
qu'il faut a priori pour vivre et ne pas
avoir potentiellement à sortir du cube
alors évidemment tout cela fait
énormément réagir concernant la volonté
d'un Neum sans aucune émission carbone
par exemple beaucoup d'entre eux ont
doute entre l'aéroport construit à côté
pour faire venir les touristes la
quantité immense de matériaux
nécessaires à sa construction ou encore
le besoin on énergie pour climatiser un
tel lieu en plein désert sans même
parler d'ailleurs de la question de
l'impact sur la biodiversité qui peut
passer par ces territoires l'impact
environnemental est déjà décrié et
l'idée donc d'un projet neutre en
carbone et très vivement contesté par de
nombreuses scientifiques aujourd'hui par
ailleurs certaines technologies
n'existent pas actuellement et si il
fallait retenir qu'un seul exemple ce
serait celui du train qui doit traverser
the line un train qui doit traverser un
bout à l'autre en moins de 20 minutes ça
impliquerait une vitesse de 510 km/h et
ça et bien c'est encore en prototype pas
sûr donc qu'ils y arrivent à temps bref
on passera toutes les critiques ou tous
les questionnements sur ce projet de m'a
déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler dans le
cadre d'autres vidéos et c'est un sujet
qui a été beaucoup traitée mais ce qu'il
faut retenir donc ici c'est ce que ça
dit de l'Arabie Saoudite ou de ce que
veut devenir l'Arabie Saoudite de
Mohamed Ben Salman en fait pour le pays
le développement de ces projets
futuristes c'est carrément ce que l'on
appelle du soft power ou encore de la
puissance douce en français c'est à dire
donc une manière d'exercer de
l'influence à l'international autrement
que par le hard power autrement donc par
la force et par le côté militaire avec
ces projets MBS veut évidemment attirer
et impressionner le monde entier et pour
ça il compte donc sur deux événements
premier événement les Jeux asiatiques
divers de 2029 qui auront lieu à trojna
d'ailleurs un aéroport a été construit
juste à côté pour accueillir les
touristes lors de cet événement et
deuxième événement c'est l'exposition
universelle le pays a proposé
d'accueillir en 2031 cette exposition
universelle et ça coïnciderait avec
l'aboutissement du projet vision 2030 on
verra donc si leurs candidatures validé
mais ne vous inquiétez pas pour MBS ce
n'est pas la seule carte qu'il a pour
tenter de promouvoir son pays je vais
découvrir la chambre en direct avec vous
c'est trop trop une activité qui nous a
vraiment au milieu après les
influenceurs aux Émirats arabes unis et
à Dubaï plus précisément et bien c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite qui a décidé de faire
appel à des influenceurs et à
différentes personnalités pour
promouvoir le pays on doit choisir nos
voitures pour rejoindre le spot ça va
être incroyable pas sûr que ça
fonctionne beaucoup pour autant je
dirais même au contraire ces voyages ont
été pas mal critiqués par la presse et
même dans les commentaires d'ailleurs
des publications de ces influenceurs il
y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de critiques et
oui visiblement beaucoup de personnes ne
sont pas dupes même s'il y a eu des
évolutions ces dernières années et je
reviens là-dessus juste après l'Arabie
Saoudite reste aujourd'hui un pays où
les droits humains et les droits des
femmes notamment sont aujourd'hui très
restreints et ça ne passe donc pas trop
alors si les influenceurs ne suffisent
pas quoi de mieux pour attirer les
foules du monde entier que d'utiliser
l'un des plus grands footballeurs de
tous les temps
peut-être que certains fans de football
qui regardent cette vidéo le savent
depuis quelques années l'Arabie Saoudite
mise de plus en plus sur le sport pour
promouvoir son influence selon plusieurs
médias il y aurait actuellement des
discussions avec Messi pour tenter de le
faire venir à terme en Arabie Saoudite
d'ailleurs il est déjà ambassadeur du
pays pour promouvoir le tourisme mais le
pays a déjà mis la main sur un autre
joueur j'ai nommé Cristiano Ronaldo qui
joue pour l'une des équipes du pays avec
un salaire de 200 millions d'euros par
an jusqu'en 2025 et oui grâce à ses
revenus générés par le pétrole l'Arabie
Saoudite est un pays très riche il fait
même partie des 20 pays les plus riches
du monde forcément ça aide à attirer des
joueurs le pays a d'ailleurs récemment
fait une offre pour tenter de racheter
le club anglais de Manchester United il
possède déjà 80% des parts de Newcastle
un autre club anglais bref MBS sort les
grands moyens et ils ne vise pas que le
foot depuis 2021 les fans de F1 ils
savent le pays a mis en place le Grand
Prix d'Arabie Saoudite un prix que l'on
retrouve donc dans le calendrier de la
saison de Formule 1 et MBS envisage même
à terme de créer sa propre écurie donc
sa propre équipe avec ses deux pilotes
sur la grille de départ enfin l'Arabie
Saoudite veut aussi devenir un pays qui
compte dans le domaine de l'art et du
divertissement avec toujours le même
double objectif première objectif un
objectif de soft power pour montrer son
ouverture au monde et à côté et bien un
objectif d'ordre économique diversifié
son économie pour reposer de moins en
moins sur le pétrole deux trois éléments
qui peuvent le montrer un ministère de
la Culture a été créé en 2018 et c'était
quelque chose de nouveau dans le pays ça
n'existait pas avant autre exemple et
bien les cinémas sont autorisés dans le
pays depuis 2018 alors qu'ils étaient
fermés depuis 35 ans par ailleurs
l’arabie Saoudite mise beaucoup sur des
partenariats avec d'autres pays pour la
construction de nouveaux musées c'est le
cas avec la France par exemple le Centre
Pompidou plus précisément qui a signé
avec l'Arabie Saoudite un accord pour la
création d'un futur Musée d'Art
Contemporain dédié aux artistes du monde
arabe mais le pays c'est également
ouvert aux artistes musicaux
ce concert par exemple a eu lieu en 2017
et ça peut paraître assez banal mais en
Arabie Saoudite c'était la première fois
en presque 30 ans d'un tel concert avait
lieu le pays avait en effet inscrit
l'interdiction des concerts depuis le
début des années 90
aujourd'hui c'est donc des artistes
comme Justin Bieber David Guetta Calvin
Harris ou encore très viscott il a
seulement quelques semaines que l'on
voit en Arabie Saoudite les festivals et
les concerts s'enchaînent depuis ce
début d'ouverture d'un point de vue
culturel et finalement assez
indispensable pour MBS aujourd'hui
indispensable pour les touristes
forcément qui s'attendent à avoir ce
genre d'activité s'ils viennent sur
place mais potentiellement indispensable
aussi pour sa population la moitié des
36 millions d'habitants d'Arabie
saoudite ont moins de 30 ans aujourd'hui
et souvent c'est donc des jeunes comme
vous et moi qui peuvent vouloir sortir
voir des matchs de foot assister à des
concerts ou autres et toujours dans
cette logique de soft power plutôt que
d'importer des produits culturels qui
pourraient venir de l'étranger et qui
sont d'ailleurs encore souvent dans
certains cas censurés il s'agit
d'investir dans le cinéma plus largement
y compris par exemple dans la création
de films ou de studios saoudien qui
peuvent à terme avoir donc cette
influence à l'étranger
en décembre 2021 par exemple le pays a
inauguré la toute première édition d'un
nouveau festival de cinéma le festival
du film de la mer Rouge et une deuxième
édition a eu lieu en 2022 pendant 10
jours donc des producteurs et des
distributeurs sont venus des quatre
coins du monde pour faire des affaires
et tous venait notamment chercher pour
leurs projets cinématographique l'argent
de l'Arabie Saoudite qui souhaite
consacrer l'équivalent de 60 milliards
d'euros au financement de ce genre de
projet de l'argent donc et des studios
le pays veut notamment faire connaître
ces infrastructures de tournage et
notamment et bien permettre des
tournages à terme justement dans le
projet NEOM dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure comme quoi vous le voyez tout
est lié derrière élément qu'on peut
noter l'Arabie Saoudite investit
également dans le jeu vidéo chez
Nintendo par exemple
le pays possède plus de 8% des parts de
l'entreprise ce qui fait de lui le plus
gros actionnaire extérieur de Nintendo
et là encore vous l'avez compris le but
est toujours de diversifier son économie
tout en étant stratégique dans les choix
pour résumer les jeux vidéo c'est cool
c'est populaire ces jeunes bref ça peut
permettre d'étendre son influence alors
est-ce que tout ça fonctionne vraiment
évidemment on pourrait parler de la
vision stratégique de l’arabie Saoudite
pendant des heures il n'en reste pas
moins qu'aujourd'hui ça reste un pays où
les droits humains sont encore très très
peu présents l'homosexualité est par
exemple considéré comme un crime et donc
passible de la peine de mort des
personnes notamment des femmes des
défenseurs des droits humains sont
régulièrement arrêtés emprisonnés et
exécuté d'ailleurs il existe aucun texte
de loi qui protège la liberté
d'expression autrement dit les Saoudiens
n'ont pas le droit de critiquer que ce
soit le gouvernement l'Islam ou encore
la famille royale au pouvoir la presse
saoudienne de la même façon et contrôlée
et le pays bloque une grande partie
d'Internet ou de certains réseaux
sociaux bref l’arabie Saoudite reste
considéré comme l'un des pires pays en
matière des droits de l'homme alors
cependant là où il y a eu des
changements ces dernières années il faut
quand même le noter c'est concernant les
droits des femmes depuis 2018 par
exemple elles peuvent conduire ce
n'était pas le cas avant j'ai pas dormi
de la nuit tellement je suis contente ça
fait des années que on a tendance à j'ai
27 ans et ça a toujours été mon rêve la
mixité homme-femme est progressivement
autorisée de la même façon dans les
lieux publics et depuis 2015 les femmes
qui ont un diplôme d'enseignement
supérieur peuvent voter alors quoi qu'on
en pense l'Arabie Saoudite sera à
scruter dans les prochaines années en
2029 par exemple lorsque par exemple
dans quelques années accueillera les
Jeux asiatiques divers et donc forcément
des milliers de personnes qui vont se
rendre sur place et qui vont regarder ou
non à la télévision ces événements alors
quelle sera à ce moment-là la réaction
internationale on a beaucoup entendu des
critiques concernant la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar que ce soit sur le plan humain
ou écologique mais malgré les appels au
boycott finalement la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar c'était avéré extrêmement suivi
bref les prochaines années vont être
très intéressantes à analyser on va
continuer à suivre tout ça sur cette
chaîne Youtube en tout cas j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura permis d'y voir
plus clair merci beaucoup à Anaïs qui
est journaliste au sein de l'équipe et
qui a travaillé sur ce sujet là pour ça
vous abonner chez mes parents encore le
cas on approche du million d'abonnés
vous ça change pas grand chose mais nous
ça nous aide énormément donc n'hésitez
pas à le faire mais c'est pas encore le
cas prenez soin de vous prenez soin de
nos proches et puis on se dit à très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo